[موسيقى]
من جانبها هي الحرب في اوكرانيا تصعد اكثر
بتكاليف الطاقه اللاخذه في الارتفاع
النظيفه
وجدت اوروبا
وبصراحه قواعد لعيبه مختلفه
للمخاطر الجيو السياسيه في العقود القادمه
اسرائيل
وتؤدي دوما الى وقوع المال والقوه في ايدي
قله من النفس مع اي الاوراق الجيو
السياسيه يتعامل عالم يتخلى عن الاعتماد
على النفط والغاز
مع هذه المرحله من الانتقال اهلا بكم في
نظام عالمي جديد
عن المكان الذي استطيع
[موسيقى]
في هولندا يظن الجميع ان الغاز متاح
بسهوله دائما
الاناره
[موسيقى]
حسنا
مصطلح الزعيم القادم
منذ بعض الوقت
سوري
من حول العالم في 80 بالمئه منها ليس
الموقف الاسلم لنا ارعدت مواضيع لكن اهمها
موضوع الطاقه من اجتماعنا بالامس
الذي يقوم عليه الاقتصاد العالمي والنظام
السياسي الدولي واذا ما فكرت بالنفط في
هذا السياق لا اظن ان اثنين يختلف الثاني
على ان النفقه اللاعب دورا كبيرا في تشكيل
العلاقات بين القوى وفي تحديدا متى نذهب
للحرب او نشنح للسلم وفي تحديد اي البلدان
واي المناطق الراس اهميه كل هذه العناصر
ترتبط بالطاقه
تواضع عقود اعتمدت اوروبا على روسيا
والشرق الاوسط لامدادها بالوقود الاحفوري
وقد زادت الحروب والنزاعات امنه هذه
العلاقه والعكس صحيح
منذ الحرب على العراق بدات ميغان وسوليفان
دراسه تاثير الوقود الاحفوري والطاقه
المتجدده في السياسات الدوليه
وحسب بل الى نظام طاقه جديد بالكامل واذا
ما نجح في الانتقال السريع فسيفتح هذا
بابا واسعا لانعدام الاستقرار واذا كنت
مهتما بفهم المخاطر الجيو السياسيه فعليك
ان تاخذ الانتقال في مجال الطاقه بعين
الاعتبار
جميعا اصدقاء في المستقبل
لينك
وفي بعض السنوات 40 في المئه من
احتياجاتنا من الغاز من روسيا من بلد واحد
ليس وضعا سليما لقد سلمنا الامر ورضينا
بهذه الاتكاليه
فيديو حساسه
ظهر ذلك جليا من خلال الصراع في اوكرانيا
في السياسه الدوليه يعد امن الطاقه قضيه
مثيره للجدل
[موسيقى]
معظم احتياجاتها من الطاقه وبالتالي احدى
اهم قضاياها تكون في التوفيق بين استيراد
ما يكفي من الطاقه من مصادر خارجيه
والمحافظه على الاقتصاد وعلى النمو
الاقتصادي والمحافظه على ازدهار شعبها
ورضاها عن انظمه السياسيه
من الطاقه
وهذه الطاقه
لذلك تجد على راس اهداف قاده الحزب
الشيوعي في الصين العمل على توفير ما يكفي
من الطاقه من الخارج للمحافظه على نمو
البلاد وعلى موقع الحزب في السلطه ورد
الشعب عن الحكم
من التبعيه الجيو السياسيه المرافقه للنفط
المستورد وبالمثل هناك رغبه واضحه لدى
اوروبا في الوصول الى مستوى اكبر من
الاكتفاء الذاتي بالنسبه لتوفير
احتياجاتها من الطاقه
في اوروبا
همم ادعموني هذا ازمه الغاز الوشيكه مقلقه
بلا شك لكنها تحقق هدفا فهي جرس انذار
يذكرنا بضروره تغيير اساليبها
سيعيد تشكيل السياسات العالميه
سياسه الخارج
من قبل الصين والولايات المتحده وغيرهما
على تغير العلاقات خلال عمليه الانتقال في
مجال الطاقه
الاكتفاء الذاتي في الطاقه هذا هو الحلم
الانتقال الطاقي الحالي يقدم هذه الفرصه
ونحن نشهد ابتعاد المصالح عن اشكال الوقود
كالنفط والغاز الى مواد نحتاجها لطاقه
نظيفه كالبطاريات وخلايا تخزين الطاقه
والثوره الصناعيه تؤدي لتغير في موازين
القوه
الارتباط بتوفر هذه المعادن لا يتعلق
الامر بدرجه الارتباط وحسب ما البي حقيقه
كون مستويات الانتاج العالمي لا تكفي
لتغطيه طلب العلم المتوقع في حال حدوث
تقدم في التحول العالمي في مجال الطاقه
كما ان هذه المعادن تتركز في عدد صغير من
البلدان فاذا جمعت هذه العوامل معا فستخرج
بوصفه من الاهتمام غير المتجانس سواء فيما
يتعلق بالبلدان التي تنتجها او البلدان
التي تصنعها
على مصادر الطاقه وعلينا ان نلجا الى ما
تحت ايدينا من مصادر الطاقه وهي مصادر
مستدامه لحسن الحظ
ايضا
نحن بحاجه الى العالمين
اعتمد على تشيلي بنسبه مئه في المئه هذا
ليس وفقا مشرقا لانه بوتي من جديد لكن على
مسافه بعد
السخريه كي نحصل على مصدر المستدامه
للطاقه علينا ان نعود في انحاء العالم
كافه وعيد فتح المناجم المغلقه واكتشف
احتياطيه جديده اندفاع نحو ذهاب اخضر بحثا
عن مواد استراتيجيه الخطب جلل ودروس
الماضي حاضره في الذهن
كما صاله رونالدو
[موسيقى]
وذلك مصري
صربيا ان يتم اكتشافه مخزون ضخم من ماده
اوليه استراتيجيه وهل سنشهد اليات للتعامل
مع الليثيوم كتلك التي شهدناها مع النفط
والغاز
[موسيقى]
على ضفاف نهر جدار بصربيا يقع منزل زلاتكو
كوكانا بيتش
ارض زلاتكو تملكها عائلتهم منذ اجيال لكن
اتضح انها تربط على كميات ضخمه من
الليثيوم العديد من المزارعين المحليين
باعوا اراضيهم لشركات التنقيب الاجنبيه
المتعطشه لكن ليس زلاتكو زلاتكو يرفض
من جمال
من قبل شركه اسمها
دي كوباني ده يخططون لبناء مصنع معالجه
يمكنه سحب 4000 الى 5000 طن من الصخور
يوميا
ونصف من المتفجرات الشهراني او الثلاثه
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
اسالك
هولندا بتدمير 20 قريه يسكنها 15 او 20
الف مواطن في واد خصيب من اجل اقامه منجما
ودفن المخلفات التنقيب عن المعادن فيه
[موسيقى]
اليوتيوب
ما بدا كم مقاومه محليه من جانب زلاتكو
وجيرانه امتد ليتحول الى حركه احتجاجيه
ضخمه
الاف السرب نزلوا الى الميادين معارضين
لخطط التنقيب عن الليثيوم المسبب للتلوث
يظهر الرئيس على شاشه التلفاز قبيل
الانتخابات الوكيكه محاولا الاحتواء
الموقف لكن دون جدو كويس
بس بكره
[موسيقى]
من تاريخ الاقتصاد العالمي برزات اهميه
مصادر مختلفه
واهميتها تتاثى من دورها في الانتاج
العالمي او في قطاع الطاقه
سيا ريو فرانكو تدرس الاثر الواقعه على
السكان في بلد غاليين بالليثيوم وتلاحظ
تغيرا عالميا في العقليه حين تعتبر المواد
الاوليه النظيفه ذات اهميه استراتيجيه
هو اهميته في انتاج احد اهميه تقنيات
الطاقه النظيفه وهي بطاريات الليثيوم
اخر لجغرافيتي تواجده فعندما تنظر
الحكومات في العالم وتتسائل من اين تاتي
هذه المعادن ثم تجده معينه يتركز انتاجها
في اماكن معينه قلقها حول ما يسمى عوائق
التزويد
[موسيقى]
الى الحافه
التي ترتدونها
[موسيقى]
او يخافون او يقلقون
على طاقه مناجم الفحم هذه
الاقتصاد الذي يحتاجونه
لكن لا اظن ان هذا مناسب للمستقبل
الصناعات المدمره التي تستخدم الوقود
الاحفوري التنقيب الحديث لا يجب ان يكون
على هذا النحو
هذا هو الهدف ان كانت مضره
من بينهم الكسندر باركور مالك شركه
ومقرها كندا
هذه عينات للمواد التي استخرجناها خلال
عمليه الحفر حيث ندخل انبوبا في الارض ثم
نخرجه الى السطح ونحدد على كل علبه مصدرها
ومن اي جزء من الحفره والعمق الذي اخرجت
منه ومن هنا نبدا عمليهنا
الارض هو كالماء لكن كما ان الماء العذب
نسبته قليله هذا هو حال الليثيوم
التي توافق المعايير الاجتماعيه والبيئيه
والماليه والتقنيه امر صعب المنازل
حاليا حاليا
الدقيق وعندما تبحث الجهات الحكوميه
والشركات عبر العالم سواء كنا نتحدث عن
الحكومه الامريكيه او تسله لن تجد الى
اربعه منتجين رئيسيين لليوم وهذا ليس
بالكثير اذا ما وقع انقلاب او اداه تغير
المناخي الى حاله طوارئ وتوقف انتاج تشيلي
فجاه فسيصبح لديك ثلاثه منتجين وليس اربعه
لهذا كما ترى يقلقهم تركز الانتاج
عن مودرن اهدافهم تنويع مصادر الانتاج
وايضا من اهدافهم تحقيق انتاج داخل حدوثهم
ليكون لديهم سيطره ونفاذ اقليميان مباشره
العالميه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
مكياج افريقيا
يبقى هذا على هذه المعادن الحيويه اليوم
[موسيقى]
كل يريد موده الاستراتيجيه قريبا من بيته
لذا يبحث الاتحاد الاوروبي جيدا في فناء
الخلفي
وبفضل مخزونها الكبير من الليثيوم اصبحت
صربيا فجاه في دائره الضوء
في المنطقه برمتها البلد يضم انواع كثيره
من الاحوال
هناك شركات شابه تذهب وتبحث عنها تجد شيئا
سه
في صربيا
اما بالنسبه لليثيوم سياسي
ما تسيل
الشاليه
سنه القادمه
ليس المهم من سيكونون هدفنا وقف استخراج
الليثيوم والبوراك معنا
نحن هنا كوباني
فيديو
انها حرب نفسيه ليست حرب تقليديه بل نوع
جديد من الحروب
[موسيقى]
الشعور بالحجه لاوروبا مستقله في مجال
الطاقه قوي لدرجه تهدد المجتمعات المحليه
المصالح العالميه كبيره والرغبه في
الليثيوم متناميه لا تحول الى الطاقه
النظيفه بدون هذا الذهب الاخطر سيناريو
كئيب تفضل الحكومات تجنب الخوض فيه
[موسيقى]
اوغندا
من المعادن النادره التي نحتاجها للهواتف
الخلويه الماضي
الباتيلايت
حقوق الانسان وشروط اخرى معقدات بما فيها
اعاده تدوير البطاريات
تنظيم البطاريات مثال على كيفيه التعامل
مع الموارد التاكيد على لم يكن مصادفه
[موسيقى]
المواد الاوليه سواء كانت طاقه او موده
اوليه
للتكنولوجيات الدفاعيه او التقنيات
الجديده كالتربينات الهوائيه
هي دوله اوروبيه
قواعد اللعب التي نتبعها
لمباراه كره القدم فهم ينزلون بمئه
لكنهم مقيدون بالمعايير البيئيه وهو امر
نحترمه تماما
ان نقدم بعض التنازلات اليس كذلك
فستنتهي المساله قبل ان تبدا
وهو ان الصين
في مجال الطاقه
او المركبات الكهربائيه فستخسرون معركه
التحكم بالثوره الصناعيه القادمه
تنقيبي الى نهايه حياه المنتج واعاده
التدوير وكل ما بين ذلك من توفير العناصر
والتصنيع والاستهلاك وسلسله التزويد ككل
ينظر اليها كاستنزاف للصراع الجيوسياسي
وهنا تبرز اهميه الاستثمار الداخلي بين
قوسين كي لا تخسر معركه تركز القوه التي
يوشك الاقتصاد العالمي على خضها
الرئيس
ليستمع نفر من قاده التظاهرات في قريه
زلاتكو للاحتفال
نصرا تحقق لكن المعركه الحقيقيه توشك على
البدر
اذا كان جزء من العالمين
تحاولين دعم خطه لاحدهم لجعل الكوكب مكان
الافضل
اذا حللنا مشكله واحدث اخرى
[موسيقى]
على استخراج الليثيوم من هنا
لكن بصراحه الناس هنا لا يقومون على شراء
السيارات الكهربائيه البعض يستطيعون لكن
نسبه كبيره من الصلب فقراء
لن تستعمله هنا اشخاص هنا اخرون سيارات
الكهربائيه وينعمون بها وان نقي بينما
نتحول نحن الى دوله مناجان
فريق ودهانات
[تصفيق]
تربيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لا اقول ان هذا سيتحدث
بناء على مساله الليثيوم لكننا لم نتطرق
بعد لزاويه العلاقات بين الدول حول
اليوتيوب تحدثنا عن الحرب ونزاعات لكن من
بين الاشياء العديده المطروحه للنقاش اذا
اصبحت صربيا عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
احتياطات الاتحاد الاوروبي من اليوتيوب
ستتوسع فجاه
انضمام الدوله
حتى البلد فيصبح لدينا انتاج من النجوم او
الكبرت او الجرافيت لا اتحدث نيابه عن
المفوضيه الاوروبيه لكن لن اتفاجا خطر هذا
ببالهم
[موسيقى]
رك
همم
فكره
ضخمه لليثيوم وان هذا مهم لفرقه عموما فيه
مومن
بشيء من الضغط
ماما
الدخول الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن حتى
الذين لا يرفضون مثل انا واستطيع ان اقول
رايي الشخصي هذا هو رئيس
اليوم
لا ندخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ابدا
الاتحاد الاوروبيه
فهل توافقون
بدافع الخوف من التلوث البيئي تشبت
المواطنون بموقفهم
لكن ماذا لو استخرج الليثيوم بطريقه نظيفه
وجدنا مبادره وعده في اعلى وادي الراي
منجما يفضي الى مخزون هائل من الليثيوم
ويمكن استخراجه باقل ضرر على البيئه
اذا هناك طريقه اخرى
الطاقه البركانيه تبعد الليثيوم عن المياه
الجوفيه الساخنه اسفل وادي الراين وهذا
يعني الا حاجه لحفر كهوف عميقه اضافه الى
استخدام حراره المياه الجوفيه لتوليد
الكهرباء
في اوروبا
سمينه من جبل ذهب
ابيض
[موسيقى]
احتياطيات الليثيوم في وادي الريان كبيره
من الشمال الى الجنوب و 40 كيلومترا من
الشرق الى الغد ما يجعل منه مصدرا كبيرا
سواء
اقل من نصف المساحه صالحا لاستخراج
الليثيوم فما يزال لدينا اكبر مصدر في
العالم من طاقه باطن الارض الحراريه
الطاقه
امريكا الجنوبيه
وهي استخلاص الليثيوم
من الارض ونمرره بالمذيب يمكنك تشبيه ذلك
بمفعول الاسفنج
ايدا الليثيوم
[موسيقى]
بيكون ستار برود يوسف
2024 او 25 بدانا اثنين كمؤسسين ونحن الان
مئه وخمسه ايضا
[موسيقى]
لصناعه الالمانيه
الليثيوم هو ماده اوليه ستشتد الحاجه لها
من اجل انتقال الناجح لكنه لا يكفي وحده
اذا ارادت اوروبا تحقيق الاستقلال في مجال
الطاقه فسيكون عليها ان تبحث اكثر
خلال 30 عاما فبدانا البحث عن مصادر
منها
الجويده لرد الفعل المفضل المتمثلين
او مواد السيراميك
قري بجريندسي الكثير من الابداع نرى هذا
في امريكا وفي اماكن في اوروبا واتوقع ان
نشهد المزيد منه مع الوقت اشعر اننا سننجد
بدائل للنسيوم وسنجد طرقا افضل لاعاده
تدويره
خلال السنوات القادمه فهذه الاشياء لا
تاتي بين عشيه وضحاها العامه
ازدادت كثيرا هذه المره ولم تصل بعد
الاغنيه
لكن الجدار كبير جدا هذه المره بفعل
التغير المناخي والتنوع الحيوي ربما بدانا
بعد فوات الاوان بل بالتاكيد بدانا بعد
فوات الاوان
قد تمكنا من الحصول على مزيد من الطاقه
للمزيد من البشر حول العالم
واعتقد ان الهدف النهائي الذي نتطلع اليه
لاقول ان لا تكون هناك تعقيدات لكن اذا ما
خيرته بين الجغرافيا السياسيه للنفط
والغاز والجغرافيا السياسيه للانتقال
الجديد في مجال الطاقه فسختار الاخيره
[موسيقى]